[Music]
on this wednesday night reaction to
quebec's proposed anti-vaxx tax
from the prime minister to the premiers
we have no intent we explore the
opposition and the support it should be
at least three to four hundred dollars
beefing up pandemic benefits to help
battered businesses what affects your
your mental health your emotional health
what else they say they need
is the party over for the british prime
minister i must
take responsibility his admission and
apology and mounting calls for him to
resign and under the influence of social
media growing urgency for the government
to act
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the new approach
quebec's premier is taking to get
everyone in his province vaccinated
against covet 19. call it a punishment
or call it an incentive the plan is to
make those who refuse to get vaccinated
pay a penalty or a fee premier francois
lego calls it a health contribution a
necessary tool he says because the
unvaccinated are more of a burden on the
health care system he's given few
details on how it would be implemented
but just the idea of it has generated
swift reaction
for and against and the province says
seven thousand people signed up for
their first shot today our coverage
begins with mike lacatura
the best path forward
is
vaccination it's a message the prime
minister has pushed for 12 months yet
millions of canadians remain
unvaccinated and while justin trudeau
wants more information about quebec's
plan to tax the unvaxed
he's also not denouncing it various
orders of government are right to look
at different ways of encouraging and
incentivizing
people to get vaccinated quebec premier
francois lagos idea of a significant
so-called health contribution for
unvaccinated adults may seem a desperate
measure to some
but some believe these are desperate
times well i think the fact that we're
seeing quebec consider this option just
really speaks to where we are at in
terms of the healthcare system being
overwhelmed and really struggling to
keep bringing itself back to meet the
needs of canadians throughout this
pandemic other premiers say they won't
be following quebec's lead no we will
not be
putting in a cove attacks saskatchewan
hasn't looked at this we have no intent
to ultimately look at a vax tax the
instruments that are in place have
achieved their goals but
so it's not something that we're
contemplating at this particular time
ontario's top doctor believes promoting
informed decisions on vaccines is
preferable to punishing people putting a
penalty on those that have not been
vaccinated has not been entertained by
this government federal measures haven't
been punitive but have prohibited
unvaccinated people from getting on
planes or trains or working in the
public service
health minister jean-yves duclos has
floated the idea of vaccine mandates
pointing to successes in the public
sector where nearly 99 percent of
federal civil servants are nearly fully
vaccinated
some countries are going further in
austria as of february 1st
vaccines will be mandatory for everyone
new chancellor olaf schultz wants the
same for adults in germany whether or
not quebec moves forward with the tax it
will have to respect the canada health
act meaning any fee imposed by the
province cannot be tied to access to the
country's free universal health care
system and prime minister trudeau says
he's been assured by the province that
quebec will respect the act
donna
all right michael couture in ottawa
thanks it is unvaccinated people in
quebec who will pay the price if this
policy is implemented so far it is just
talk lots of talk as mike armstrong
reports
if there's ever been a topic made for
talk radio debating taxing the
unvaccinated may be it christo what do
you say it should be at least three to
four hundred dollars it shouldn't be an
amount it should be a percentage of an
income that the people having when smoke
became a secondhand smoke issue we
banned it right this is not something
new because of covid be fair quantify
how much of a burden these people aren't
back they get some flu are placed on the
health care system people need a
sedentary lifestyle people eat fast food
and then make it fair tax them too and
we get rid of the universal health care
system all together and be fair about it
while quebec's proposed anti-vaxx tax
may only apply to quebecers the debate
is affecting canadians across the
country
dave what do you think about lego the
issue as they say lit up the lines in
toronto yeah i don't like it with some
nervous about a slippery slope and what
could come next
it frightens me and others applauding
the quebec premier's tough approach he's
angry he's probably frustrated he has a
lot of guts so
like it or not i respect the man for
that
in vancouver different conditions but
the same questions a recent poll found
about 60 percent of canadians would
support some sort of a health surcharge
for the unvaccinated that's about the
ratio of support the idea is getting on
bc radio and on the line in langley hi
anne what do you think i i really think
they need to pay their way
that's despicable to say that it's
despicable to say that you're going to
charge people quite frankly i'm sick and
tired of us collectively being held
hostage by sadly the previous caller who
probably gets his medical advice from
joe rogan if i can't control what's in
my bloodstream then we're not in a free
society anymore this is communism not a
good idea no for or against whether it's
calgary or st catherine street in
montreal this one has people talking and
that may be part of the reason for the
proposal quebec's health minister says
the day the anti-vaxx tax was announced
appointments for first doses jumped
seven thousand people booked whether it
ever happens or not it may already be
having an impact mike armstrong global
news montreal
in ontario the number of people in the
hospital with covid 19 now has hit
another high there are more than 3 400
people in hospital with the virus that's
up 228 from yesterday 505 of them are in
intensive care about 12 percent of
eligible people in ontario are
unvaccinated they account for more than
45 percent of people in icus the ontario
government is giving parents and
teachers more information today on the
plan to get students back to in-class
learning starting next week every
student teacher and staff member will
get two rapid antigen tests more will be
rolled out when the government has the
supply
our new approach focuses on empowering
parents and students empowerment means
parents have the test in their home can
perform it in their home
and can make the diagnosis in their home
with greater convenience
there are also new protocols for
notifying ontario parents about
potential covet outbreaks the province
says parents will only be told when 30
percent of the school is absent in class
learning is set to resume in ontario on
monday
i know the anguish that they have been
through
unable
to mourn their relatives
unable to live their lives as they want
or to do the things
they love
and i know the rage
they feel
with me
[Music]
and with the government i lead when they
think that in downing street itself
the rules are not being properly
followed by the people who make the
rules
well that is britain's prime minister
trying to hang on to his job some senior
members of boris johnson's own party
have joined the chorus of voices calling
for him to resign he admitted today he
did attend an event in the garden of his
residence in the middle of the lockdown
last may when the public was told to
meet only one person outside his claim
that he didn't know it was a party is
being laughed at but as crystal
gamansing reports the threat to his
leadership is serious
mr speaker i want to apologize
i know that millions of people
across this country have made
extraordinary sacrifices a scandal quite
literally in his own backyard could end
boris johnson's time in power the prime
minister previously said he was furious
and ordered an inquiry over allegations
government staff members held parties in
2020 when the country was in lockdown
now he acknowledges he attended one of
those gatherings and while he apologized
he tried to justify his attendance i
believed implicitly that this was
a work event however the invite obtained
by itv news encouraged people to make
the most of the lovely weather in the
garden at number 10
for socially distanced drinks this is a
business meeting
until it's a party outside parliament
demonstrators called the pm's actions
indefensible demanding he resign
inside the opposition leader did the
same it's his defense that he didn't
realize he was at a party
it is so ridiculous
that it's actually offensive to the
british public
more than 150 000 people in the uk have
died as a result of covid 19. this wall
of hearts right across from parliament a
visual reminder of the impact of the
virus now not only is there grief and
anger but embarrassment
i'd say there's an affront to
to you to me to everyone who's
sacrificed
during covet it's a serious business
shouldn't have done it an apology is not
enough it's not okay to simply say i'm
sorry i thought it was a work meeting i
mean you're smart on that you run a
country
how much longer he'll be running the
country is the question johnson has long
been known as a savvy politician a
survivor but some conservative
backbenchers are now talking about
triggering a non-confidence vote
crystal gomansing global news
london prince andrew will have to face a
civil suit in the u.s over allegations
he sexually assaulted a teenager in
2001. lawyers for the duke of york
argued virginia duprey's lawsuit be
thrown out in large part because of a
settlement she reached with jeffrey
epstein in 2009 duffray claims epstein a
convicted sex offender set up sexual
encounters with the prince when she was
17 years old prince andrew has denied
the allegations but a new york judge
ruled the settlement didn't involve the
prince and the case can continue it
could be hurt in court later this year
novak djokovic now admits he broke
self-isolation rules last month when he
had coveted 19 and met a journalist
claiming he didn't want to let the
reporter down he's also admitted he made
a false declaration on his travel form
claiming he had not traveled within two
weeks of arriving in australia recent
reports show he was in spain and serbia
that error contributed to his visa being
revoked upon arrival in australia
djokovic who is unvaccinated has since
had his visa reinstated but the
australian government is again
considering whether to revoke it today
he carried on training for the
australian open
the pandemic has been a brutal blow to
many businesses coming up how ottawa is
extending benefits is it enough
businesses relying on the federal
pandemic support program known as ceba
will get more time to pay it back the
government has extended the repayment
deadline for the interest-free loans to
the end of 2023.
it's welcome news for many but as
abigail beeman reports it's not enough
for others
sports town soccer's doors may be open
but omicron means traffic is slow it's
months where you're going into work and
you're almost dreading that you're going
in because you just know there's going
to be no business
you know and just how it affects your
your mental health your emotional health
craig burnham expanded operations right
before the pandemic hit and has spent 22
months trying to adapt that includes
navigating the maze of federal supports
that we're extending
the canada emergency business account
the ceba now has an extra year to pay
that back there's a little bit of
instant relief for sure they will be
able to have until december 31st of 2023
now to repay their loan we've heard from
businesses that they're looking for this
flexibility the seba provided up to
sixty thousand dollars to nearly nine
hundred thousand businesses across
canada if repaid by the end of twenty
twenty three up to twenty thousand
dollars will be forgiven it's been
likely the largest emergency relief
program for small businesses across
canada the canadian federation of
independent business applauds the
extension but says ottawa needs to go
further to help with so many desperately
trying to keep the lights on we believe
that the sibo loans should now be raised
to 80 000
50 of the overall loan should be
forgivable and we believe greater access
should be given to new businesses and
smaller businesses that right now are
excluded from the program burnham says
the seba didn't go very far it allowed
him to catch up on and then cover some
rent but everything helps in an era of
exhaustion
we're aging exponentially more so than
small business owners normally would the
cfib had also been calling for a longer
extension until 2024 instead of 2023.
the small business minister was asked
about that wednesday but didn't directly
answer abigail beeman global news ottawa
the philippines and south korea have all
suspended imports of canadian beef
following the discovery of a case of mad
cow disease this strain which was
detected in one alberta cow last month
is not believed to be transmissible to
humans it's the first case reported in
six years the ban could affect more than
270 million dollars in beef exports
annually though industry leaders say it
isn't expected to last long
in bc heavy rain continues to drench the
south coast and vancouver island some
areas could get more than 150
millimeters of rain
an abbotsford proactive sandbagging is
underway to try to prevent localized
flooding snow melt combined with all
that rain could raise water levels again
and cause pooling on roads it's been two
months since that city and parts of the
fraser valley were devastated by
flooding environment canada anticipates
the heavy rain will ease by this evening
[Music]
ahead after years of the dangerous
influence of social media is it too late
for ottawa to step in
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
global news is taking a closer look at
the impact social media has on all of us
we're starting with an analysis of
whether the government can or should
play a role in regulating social media
companies and gabiola has our first
installment of influenced there's entire
teams of engineers whose job is to use
your psychology against you what was
once social media's great secret is now
out in the open last september facebook
whistleblower francis haugen provided
evidence proof she says the company knew
its platforms prioritized profits over
its users well-being and that its
products harm children and stoke
division facebook rebranded itself as
meta in late october a spokesperson for
the company's canadian division tells
global news for years metta has done
extensive work in bullying suicide
self-injury and eating disorder
prevention and we'll continue to look
for opportunities to help people
struggling suleiman ahmed coaches
businesses to leverage social media for
bottom line results but he worries about
the influence social media has on his
three children i think that that needs
to be more carefully scrutinized by
government and regulators and other
people
not just left to the whims of social
media platforms in the last parliament
the liberal government introduced bills
to address online hate and privacy
concerns but they died when parliament
was dissolved for the 2021 election
during the campaign the liberals pledged
to bring back new bills within their
government's first 100 days to combat
harmful content on social media so far
nothing new
just the heritage department saying it
will continue to consult canadians
experts and stakeholders on how best to
tackle these complex issues while
upholding fundamental rights we're
laggards we're behind
australia we're behind germany we're
behind the united kingdom cracking down
on foreign tech giants isn't easy it's
really difficult to compel them to do
what they don't want to do what they
can't do
because it goes against their business
models the root of the problem the more
we click the more we engage the more
they earn that's given rise to
algorithms that amplify inflammatory
content it's a global concern in canada
opposition mps say they want a measured
collaborative approach that brings tech
titans to the table we want to see
enough approach where we're not unduly
restricting you know the freedom of
speech freedom of expression of
canadians who want to be able to express
themselves online algorithms are driving
extremist content the breakdown of
social discourse there has to be
accountability many observers are
calling for immediate action after a
quarter century of inaction
donna all right and gaviola in toronto
thanks part two of our influence series
rolls out on saturday it's about people
who use their online following to give
financial advice apparently known as
finnfluencers
living like snow kings next in alberta
family's cool construction for a winter
hangout
in alberta warm chinook winds are a
welcome relief from a stretch of frigid
weather and heavy snow well one family
decided to make the best of all of it
building a multi-room mansion and
spending time together doing it quinn
campbell takes us on a tour
this mountain of snow has been a labor
of love for the preet family
this is the entrance they've created a
snow cave mansion but it's not their
first one
four times actually the first year like
one room next year two
next one
plus nuclear this year
like
three bedrooms and the party room each
year their creations get bigger and
better oldest brother micah says the
hardest part this time was after all the
digging was done i would say it's pretty
much getting situated when we were going
to sleep in it that's right they spent
the night inside the cave soaking up
some family time me and my three kids
and my brother and one of his kids we
spent the night saturday night we had a
pizza party and settlers of catan until
about one in the morning and then we all
crawled into our sleeping bags and if
you're wondering what it's like to sleep
in the cave
my mom was sleeping but
on the mattress in a sleeping bag with
blankies i almost thought i was in my
trailer for a second it was cold at
first
and then
we brought a bunch of different heaters
in now the boys are hoping this year's
shoveling pays off they've posted the
mansion online inviting people to pay
for a night's stay hoping to save up for
something special same as my bigger
brother's a nintendo switch
we're both saving up for one it's not a
bad lesson to learn that if you work
hard you can get something out of it so
that's
maybe one of dad's ulterior motives here
southern alberta weather is forecasted
for a rapid warm-up so you might want to
book early with these budding
entrepreneurs before your chance at
sleeping in a snow mansion melts away
quinn campbell global news
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is near st catharines
ontario we'd love to see your canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]